هذا وحظر الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس من
خطوره الثمار ممارسات الحكومه الاسرائيليه
واي خطوات ضم او اعمال احاديه الجانب قد
تقدم عليها الحكومه الاسرائيليه المرتقبه
خلال تلقيه اتصال هاتفيه من الممثل الاعلى
للسياسه الخارجيه والامس الاتحاد الاوروبي
يجوز البوريل ليله امس اكد على انه بات من
ضروري البدء بمسار سياسي ينهي الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لارض دوله فلسطين وفق قرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه
تثق بالدعم الاوروبي للقضيه الفلسطينيه في
المحافل الدوليه مع اهميه الاعتراف بها
الاتحاد الاوروبي الثابت والدعم لحقوق
الشعب الفلسطيني
وقضيته العادله العالم الاتحاد الاوروبي
لبناء المؤسسات الفلسطينيه وتعزيز سبل
التعاون في جميع المجالات